how about when i got a ticket yesterday
for riding my bike did i show you the
ticket telling the story
no no don't make them look bad though
the guys but they're oh they got the
rangers were great
they come up and i was just making fun
because they were in a mask in the
middle of nowhere
yeah and uh i go really fellas masks
when we get covered out here
come on take the mask up they take the
mask they did yeah they took them out
guys and uh they must have been like oh
[ __ ] yeah i was like come what are we
doing do they know who you were
uh the big guy did oh god the big guy
did and i go uh
what are we doing i said you may take
out here he goes dude we don't want to
do it either i go i get it man don't
worry about it i'm going to talk my way
out of it and pardon me want to give him
a fake name and take off
but the grown man of me was like yeah
just deal with it i know who you are
bubba
yeah don't give them don't say my name
is chet stevens
all right
passed away i never expect to get
recognized ever and i'm i'm with my wife
at the time and i'm sitting there
i'm complaining about it no i'm i want
to hear your story but i'll go back it's
to your point
as i'm sitting there complaining i'm
like what the [ __ ] but the food was
supposed to come and i'm being a
complete dick and she goes
hey you're being recognized by three
people right now
you can't do this so i have to be
[ __ ] like all nice and stuff you just
can't do it
i was like okay i'll be nice sorry so
you're only nice because i recognize you
you dick yeah i just didn't want to be a
[ __ ] it's like when i complained to
the [ __ ]
manager because he charged me for
something i made a cena walked out
and then the guy goes to the what do you
charge you for this this fake bacon
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] bacon and i go
where did you charge me for this i go
and he goes yeah we'll take it off
it's too late i'm out i'm out i go and
then i then they
called me and they said you know he's a
fan he felt really bad and of course i'm
like
i'll give him free tickets i'm sorry i
feel terrible i call back
you're a hothead i have a [ __ ] text
relationship with you
enjoy your fans you should enjoy your
fans you're lucky i'm never a dick it's
just i
sometimes i i get a little spazzy but go
back to your [ __ ] story
i'm sorry uh nope story's over now
i gotta they did give me a ticket but
it's a low fine no no this week it's
like it's like 40
yeah he goes and i you know i've been
out here every day they go really i go
how many days is it they're like like 50
some days they go i've been on this bike
path
for 50 days in a row and he goes jesus i
go i know how much to stick it he goes
we're giving you the lowest fine
possible like 25 40 bucks i'm went sweet
see you tomorrow fellas they started
laughing
of course see you tomorrow see you
tomorrow worth it they went i'm sure
they knew it they're like i'm sure i'm
in the middle of nowhere then you say
are you guys going to be around here
where are you going to be you think we
don't know man yeah they're like we
don't know man
i was like because i i have other paths
i can take they're like just do your
thing man
and then he goes and then i go what are
we doing i go dude
look where we're at i go you're a biker
goes yeah i go welcome to the club
so thick boy bike club because he's a
big dude he goes i know i go here's the
thing dude
you're a biker how hard is it to get out
here he goes pretty tough i go we're in
the middle of nowhere dude
the only thing i've seen is a bobcat
don't think i'm getting kovit from that
yeah and he goes i agree i go so
he goes but the problem is if a thousand
people think like you and get out here
that's the problem i go
papa if a thousand people come out here
they're in shape aren't they goes big
time ago
if we all get covered we're gonna be
fine and i said also the son kills it we
know this he goes
we don't know that i go we do dude we
know we know that
well so i try to do the same thing you
did try to build a rapport
the rangers sitting there or you know
and i wanted to go up the
there's a culver city place where
there's stairs you can go up and look
out
so i want to drive shut down so i i pull
in
cops there and i go and he went mirror
like that because
he thought i was going to go so i get
out of my car and i go over and i go
hey garcetti's a dick right what a [ __ ]
he is what the [ __ ] is this he's a [ __ ]
and the guy goes dude he goes he's not a
[ __ ] we'd have a thousand
people crammed up there and it'd be a
big problem he's wearing a mask
he had no choice he had his hands up
like this
dude they're so open yeah i go oh really
like oh okay i'll see he goes and he
goes yeah all right he just
i was embarrassed that that one makes a
little more sense if it's like you know
i don't think i don't think they shut
down anything i don't think nothing
especially when it comes to outdoor
activities because we know sun helps
everything yeah and just for
mental health i think the sun's probably
the best thing you can do
but uh it is strange well well with the
bioluminescence now you know that
there's for the algae
now when it gets churned up you can go
out to the beach now at night and it's
like that it looks all it's crazy
it it glows so the beaches in manhattan
beach and
[ __ ] venice beach and dude packed
yeah
and today and when they try to clear it
out in venice people are like nah
they try to do it in manhattan beach the
same thing they're just like you guys
got to get out of here
like nah nobody cares it's a bigger
costume
yeah i think we'll be all right we're
getting over the hump like when i posted
that those people gave me a ticket in
the parks
dude when i say people are upset i mean
up
not the not the younger down the older
demo ups because
that's right they're taking away all
right well i'm like whoa dude well i'll
be fine i'll be back tomorrow like you
don't understand
it starts with how how much how much
freedom are you letting take away from
you
so when i posted about eric garcetti uh
and i was
criticizing him uh and and being
dramatically
dramatic yeah being dramatic i called
him a tyrant stuff i was being dramatic
with strong language
uh i i didn't i don't read my comments
but will sasso called me and said you
got a lot of really negative stuff and
i'm a little worried
that people are going to take it out of
context well he was worried about me but
but the point is
it was it was young people who don't who
don't understand
or have haven't had they don't have the
background they don't realize your
background
that's their knowledge of history so i'm
very i'm very sensitive to it so but
people who are educated like yourself
and i'm not but but i'm struggling
i'm getting there but even tim kennedy
like he was like they gave you a [ __ ]
ticket yeah like yeah dude
yeah he's like this is ridiculous blah
blah blah but they because they know
they know what obviously this is
americans are vigilant
americans should be always very
suspicious of their government we've
always been close
when they gave me my ticket and i
[ __ ] fell on my bike and i got
strawberry all over my back
and i'm listening rage against the
machine oh dude you're american oh
[ __ ] you're mad i want to start a
[ __ ] revolt yeah
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected